hello and welcome once again to Android
design in action I'm your host Roman
Nurik hey guys my name's Adam Akash and
today we have a special guest visiting
us from London hey I'm Nick butcher it's
good to be here in person shooting a
show rolling just a little head across
the Atlantic so today's episode is about
the onboarding experience basically
everything from the point in which the
user you know download maybe finds your
app in the Play Store installs it and
then starts you know using it so
basically kind of that initial those
crucial few moments between the point of
which you know they install and they
start running we're going to talk about
ways to make that optimal basically as
optimal as possible the old saying
you're going to get one chance to make a
first impression this is what they show
you what about exactly exactly so with
that let's jump into the slides and I'm
particularly proud of this title card we
have here for onboarding onboarding get
it yeah like a snowboard boarding you're
on a board in like so so let's get in
here so the first thing we wanted to
talk about was that last week where I
guess two weeks ago we did an episode on
our top ten I guess anti-patterns
or common UX issues that we saw during
the review and number two basically you
know one removed from the last one was
it was a poor onboarding user experience
and then included a couple of things you
know requiring registration up front
using splash screens we're gonna talk
about all the details here but we wanted
to spend an entire you know Android
design in action episode just talking
about this because it's so so crucial so
the first thing is about splash screens
Adam you don't talk about splash screens
yeah so as we mentioned the other week
don't show them let's remember a sort of
content first principles here a splash
screen is really not content it's just
another roadblock another hurdle in the
way to the user getting to your
application and the actual content in
your application now of course some
people will say well I really want to
make sure my brand is recognized that
the user knows my brand well in Android
you know we still think brand is very
important of course but you can use the
action bar
icon and of course theming and and and
sort of selecting that accent color to
really show off your brand instead and
as you can see here in in the screenshot
it's Google Play sort of a pretty good
example of of using that icon and and
the sort of accent color to really sort
of show off the different silos within
the different Google Play Store and you
know a bunch of people may think well a
lot of people think that you know splash
screens are important for when you have
you know content that you need to load
before you you know show your UI and I'd
say my rebuttal to that is you know you
you don't necessarily need to block the
entire UI right there's probably
something that you can show a value at
least show the top level navigation of
your app you know you can always show
you know a loading spinner or a really
friendly loading spinner something that
involves your brand even like like it
doesn't have to be the you know the
built-in loading spinner you can show
that in place where content will show up
you don't necessarily need to block
everything and have the user sit there
patiently waiting just looking at your
you're pretty logo before actually
showing your UI it's actually a good
chance to let them start exploring and
learning the about the you know
different sections in the app rather
than you know just showing them you know
nothing basically
yeah like even if the content isn't
there maybe they can open the drawer and
see what's available there maybe think
they can go to settings and see what
settings are available they can do other
things potentially in the application
yeah okay and the worst offenders on the
splash screens are the splash screens
which decided to go full fullscreen and
completely hide away the status bar like
that's a double don't do it all the ones
that playing the sound or music at the
front yes exactly
oh actually one of my favorites is you
get the splash screen up and then you
press back or you press home or
something because you just don't want to
use the app anymore and then you know
splash screen lasts for three seconds
but then you press back and then three
seconds later the actual next screen
just shows up randomly because the the
splash screen hasn't recognized that
you've backed out of it so it's just
that there are so many things that can
go wrong with splash screens and there's
a very poor user experience just don't
use them at all all right I think we
covered
we've beaten that dead horse or whatever
I'm really better all right anyway let's
move on so the next thing is we wanted
to cover is tutorials so we're gonna
spend some time talking about a couple
of main sections of onboarding I mean
parts to onboarding the first will be
tutorials and we'll talk about login
flow and then finally I think we'll talk
about on-screen overlays so for
tutorials one thing before we jump into
all the details we do want to mention
that there is a pretty good coverage of
a lot of these things in the Android
design guide so if you visit this link
here you'll you'll see kind of these
specifics on on when and when not to
show unsolicited help
so tutorials are one of those examples
of unsolicited help basically help that
you're kind of pushing to the user
without them actively requesting for
requesting it rather so we very clearly
kind of advise against it you know
they're interruptions they're usually
not necessary and so on and so generally
you know this is something that's
covered in our guidelines but you know
besides I wanted to kind of add
additional color I guess to to some of
these guidelines and kind of explain
some of them and the reasoning for them
so one of the first things that you
should you know think about is you know
there's a comfort there's a couple of
types of tutorials right there's speed
bump
tutorials mandatory tutorials that you
need to kind of go through before you
get into the app and we'll talk about
that in a second that's the type of
thing that you shouldn't do and the
reason that you shouldn't do them is
generally that you know it's it's a sign
that you actually may need to simplify
your app maybe there's too much going on
maybe your app is just not simple enough
and so certainly that it's it's
generally a bad sign if you think you
need like a pretty complex onboarding
flow some ways around using kind of
speed bump tutorial style is is using
you know something like what Google Play
Movies is doing here and it's it's still
you know communicating value still you
know telling the or I guess expressing
the value proposition of the app but
it's using it is doing so in a very
direct and contextual way so info cards
is one of the things
we'll play Google Play Movies features
it's one of the features that they have
basically you know when you're watching
a movie if you press pause you actually
see information about the character on
screen but idea here is that you know we
could have thrown up a tutorial that
forces you to go through it but you know
we did in here so the the idea here was
that once you get to the point at which
you know this becomes this starts to
become interesting like the user may
start caring about this at this point we
actually show this card or this this uh
this tutorial card against and they can
obviously very easily dismiss it or they
can just ignore it that you know if they
just start scrolling down they'll see
their content so it's it's very passive
it's not super obtrusive but it does
communicate the value and it doesn't in
a contextual way if I was in a different
section of the app perhaps it would show
me a you know a different kind of hint
that there's a future there I think the
key to this kind of goods tutorial if
you will is it's non-blocking I think
anything which is like blocking like
especially modal dialogues one of my
personal pet peeves anything that's like
you saying to the user hey I know better
than you what you need to be doing now
is kind of aggressive and this kind of
breaks any flow or any task they were
trying to accomplish so I think well
this is you know it's still unsolicited
help I guess it's not that doesn't have
that blocking feature or to it which
makes it so much better yeah so just to
specifically talk about on I guess speed
bump style tutorials these are the kind
of tutorials where you know you see here
is an example you basically you know
flip through a couple of pages and maybe
at the end there is like a sign up or
something but it's basically like this
is not the app this is a separate flow
before you get to the actual app that is
mandatory so this is definitely one how
many of these screens people actually
even read how many they just see this
animated on how do I get past this and
just mash that button yeah and actually
you know I will say we should probably
admit at this point you know one of our
reference app the Google i/o app has a
speed bump not a tutorial but it's a
different onboarding flow as Duffey
something that we should try to address
for for the next
but here you know some of these things
that you should think about if you
absolutely have to do something like
this if management you know sends down
the the word that you must have this
kind of tutorial flow definitely allow
immediately skipping so don't force the
user to go next next next next next and
then get started so gives you given the
user two or give them the option to skip
right away and you know also you know
Nick will talk about this in depth later
but you know if you're going through
like you know a couple screens that tell
you about the app and then at the very
end you kind of have to you know start
doing if to kind of like you know make
decisions like sign up or register or
whatever that's just another you know
way to block and stop the funnel of
engagement with your app so definitely
try to avoid these kinds of speed bump
tutorials
I think we've we've talked about speed
bump tutorials quite a bit but there's a
couple of other tutorial type things you
can do to educate users about your app
to communicate the value proposition the
first and this is very obvious very
simple but you know doing so via your
Google Play listing a lot of the things
a lot of the features that are available
in the developer console are there so
that you can kind of have a conversation
with your users at the perfect time
right before they install right before
they start using your app so things like
the product video those are very
important Google keep is actually a
really good example when you press play
here you know this is actually it has
pretty high level prominence on the page
so you know draws your attention to this
this video you start pressing play and
the video that Google keep has provided
is it has a very strong narrative it
actually walks you through one kind of
one flow one user using the app actually
talks about the features but you
actually see the person interacting with
the UI so it's actually it's a nice way
to kind of imagine yourself in their
shoes you can kind of fill in the gaps
this is how I would probably use the app
and then obviously screenshots you know
screenshots are a really good way to
communicate what your app does
especially if you're doesn't
your UI design is very good and very
clear it can emit you can immediately
kind of understand what the app does and
how it works just by looking at the
screenshot one thing I would say on the
screenshots as well is be careful the
order you put them in quite often I'll
see screenshots uploaded for an
application and it seems like they're in
the order in which you might go through
the application so in some apps I've
even seen you know a splash screen like
that motor this is the first screenshot
and then the login screen and then maybe
further down the line perhaps you know
once you have into the actual content
within the application and that's a real
shame because well as you can see here
and I screenshot from the year from the
web there's only room for one or two and
this is even more exaggerated when
you're on a device so you'll probably
see the video maybe one screenshot
perhaps half with the second one coming
in here so you really want to be showing
your hero moments the thing that really
clearly expresses what this application
is all about first and then forget about
these other ancillary screens for sure
and of course showing screenshots for
different form factors don't forget to
do that as well yeah because you know if
I'm on a device if I'm on a 10-inch
tablet I want to see what its gonna look
like you know on my device if I'm gonna
for an inch phone I want to see exactly
what its gonna look at kind of fun so
alright moving on another way to
communicate again your value proposition
or educate your users and give them a
tutorial about your content it's through
the empty state and it's actually one of
my favorites not because this is
specifically my app but there's one of
my favorite opportunity moments is in
the empty states so you know most apps
these days have collections of things
you know they have screens where there's
collections of things collections and
movies collections of in this case
extensions for a you know a clock
there's a lots of different you list too
often we see developers missing the
opportunity of that empty state when
there's nothing in that list you know
use that as the opportunity to talk to
your user
tell them how to add things to that list
why they should add things to that list
you know actually put buttons in there
in that empty state they'll let them
take action fix the problem of the empty
state generally people don't want an
empty state they wanted to be
populated right so one of the ways in
which you could do that is you could
just simply use that empty state for in
all sorts of things in this example this
is the - clock app that I wrote you
actually you know before you add any
extensions you get greeted with this
screen here and then you can press this
button - to add an extension as soon as
you add something you kind of start
seeing the full populated list so that
and it's very easy to do from a
development standpoint you basically
just provide an empty view for the list
yeah quite commonly you might imagine
well quite often I see screens which
might be like this on the left but it's
just empty screen with maybe a small
plus in the action bar and as such a
missed opportunity yeah one thing I will
say here is that there's just a bit too
much text here it probably just be very
visual be very kind of you know invert
not really immersive but just be very
visual in this screen if possible here I
kind of didn't do that anyway so let's
move on to the next screen another
important way to to communicate you know
your value proposition to explain to
users how to you know use your app is to
pre-populate it with with how you like
to say bootstrapped content right so you
know when you this is an example from
Michael Pardo as an app called quotes
and gives you your stock quotes
obviously and so one way he could have
designed this app is that when you first
install it and you open it up it just
has no quotes in there right it is just
a blank you know set of it's a blank
list and it doesn't show you any
interesting data it maybe just shows you
that the S&P index or whatever but what
he decides to do here is that you set it
to actually pre populate your your
portfolio with a couple of common stocks
here they have a cake I'm not sure if
there's like Cheesecake Factory pizza
which is probably one of the delivery
services and so you kind of immediately
see the value of the app you immediately
see the data you're gonna be working
with you know obviously you can you can
very quickly remove them you just long
press select them all and just remove or
you can just add to it but it's actually
just a very nice simple way to just
immediately get started so I think that
was it for tutorials any parting words
on tutorials before we move on guys
nothing let's cut it go already let's do
it Nick take away for login registration
yeah says one of my pet peeves is the
login experience and registration so the
first thing I'd say for a login is that
you should really be delaying it until
it's kind of absolutely necessary just
like this kind of speed bump tutorials
that we looked at earlier it's another
thing to do when you're already kind of
quite cognitively loaded like the first
time you run an application there's a
lot going on right you're kind of
getting used to it like you know the way
it looks and feels the way the
navigation is laid out you're
understanding like what the app is doing
and if you've liked throwing on all
these extra layers of stuff then it's
just a lot for the user to process so by
far and away I'd say delay it until the
last moment possible and yet the second
point I want to make here is people are
probably more likely to actually
completely log on if they can clearly
understand why it's necessary so an
example of this a great example of this
is I was shown here is the tumblr
application so when you install and
tumblr you you know the opportunity to
log on but you don't have to you can
immediately start using the application
you can explore different tumblr blogs
and you can actually take kind of logged
in type actions so for example here I
haven't actually logged into the
application but I've already been able
to go through and start following people
and if I were to then decide to log in
or sign up it would then take all those
actions which I've already done and you
know just merge them into the account
I've just created so it's a truly you
know wonderful example and in this
example here as well so if once I
followed a blog if I try to do any
actions that obviously requires logging
separate rights like like it or comment
on something at that point it then says
hey you need to be logged in to do this
and I can clearly understand why like
it's demonstrated its value to me
already and I'm much more likely I think
to complete it it's kind of like an
inherent you know it's a very contextual
you know almost like direct manipulation
sense that like it's very clear that
when I'm pressing this and I see a
sign-in dialogue there's you know the
reason to sign in is because I you know
this won't work without that whereas if
you were to ask somebody to sign in in
the very
as part of that tutorial flow you know
there there's no expression of value
right it's not clear it's very indirect
right if it's even there at all right
absolutely
okay and the next step is when you do go
on to go to provide log on like logging
on can be kind of painful experience it
often involves you know data entry which
isn't always the easiest and it's often
a pain for you as well or having to kind
of like manage and secure passwords and
so on and so forth so an alternative
might be is to consider using some of
the kind of common love on providers so
people are likely to have a bunch of
accounts on their device already so you
might have a Google account a Facebook
account Twitter accounts and these
common providers and they offer much
faster and easier login services so yeah
we're particularly a fan of the Google+
loan because most Android users what
every Android user has a gmail account
to sign into the Play Store so there's a
good chance they'll be able to log in
with that and and another thing is you
know even with with Facebook right I
mean a lot of users have Facebook
installed when you use their SDK rather
than kind of using a separate you know
web-based flow when you when you use the
SDK you actually benefit from the users
account already on the device so you
know you don't even have to actually
type in your Facebook username and
password our Facebook email and password
you basically you know touch it it knows
that you already logged in and asks you
to confirm and so on and obviously with
Google+ it's the same way it's it's
actually a great seamless yeah it's very
very seamless very much worth it
definitely
oh you at one point we're going to make
on that is to include an email
alternative some people just aren't that
comfortable and you know this perhaps
might be worried as it's going to
publish stuff to my timeline and so
forth and some people just open it first
for it so you know while we definitely
recommend this is a great way to go then
we would definitely say include an
alternative yep alright and as an aside
like while we're talking about login one
of my you know favorite things is you
know when he actually removed the need
to login all together and that's offered
quite quite neatly I think by and the
Google+ sign-in so if you choose to go
down that route and you only have a
popular web property if you the user
signs in on the web properties in the
same Google+ account it'll actually pop
up and offer them hey would you like to
install the Android app at the same time
so it's a great great you know discovery
mechanism but there's simply the
greatest thing is that the user it will
be automatically logged in already in
the Android app so you skip the need for
this altogether fantastic yes I mean
it's one of the best ways to remove
friction right I mean that that's what
we're that's probably it you know the
business folks are always thinking about
is you know how do we it's always about
the funnel right how do we maximize the
fun how do we you know minimize the
roadblocks and the funnel this is one of
the best ways to do that cool so that's
particularly fun I say I'm from looking
and we're talking about the registration
steps so I want to say here that do
offer to sign up on device I find it
quite frustrating when an application
hasn't implemented like a registration
step so it kind of boots me out to a web
view or something like that which might
have you know worse kind of data entry
and form filling kind of capabilities so
I definitely urge you to kind of include
it within your application but try to
make it as painless as possible
so as we're saying data entry on mobile
devices isn't always the most fun
experience so especially at this
critical time we trying to get someone
to sign up for your service and you
think of that funnel so you want to keep
it as painless as possible so here's a
kind of concocted example which is kind
of trying to prove a point like social
security number yeah make it as simple
as possible don't like ask someone to
enter an email address on the phone and
then confirm it I mean that's pretty
pretty painful right and summer steps so
then walk you through some improvements
to this screen here so the first thing
I'd say is to remove repetitive or
non-essential fields here so already
this screen is starting to look a little
bit better if we got rid of like you
know how to repeat those your email
password and some extra information
which might not be like completely
essential to the signup and you can put
maybe prompt for it later on when they
understand the value proposition of that
or on a different kind of medium so
already this is time to look a little
bit better the next step one of my
personal favorites here is to suggest an
email if the user starts like filling it
in so your Android device knows a lot
about you you know your he knows that
email addresses maybe some user names
that you've entered so once the user
starts typing or you could offer this as
a pick from the list if you want then do
suggest one thing to be wary of I've
seen some implementations of this where
they just you know see if there's
already an email address on the device
and then you're just pre-fill it but
they don't let you pick so we kind of
like isn't great for users if you have
more than one account on the device so
definitely let them switch between
multiple accounts if they have that but
yeah already this has got so much easier
just with a couple of key taps I can
just pick from this list here and one of
the things that one of the questions
that they're actually we discussed
earlier was how do you actually show
this list right you know do you show an
additional affordance to pick and
certainly if you use the Google Play
services SDK there's actually something
called account picker that's a dialog
that pops up and that actually doesn't
require any permissions and so if you
want to show like the account picker
dialog you could have a good additional
button next to this field rather than a
drop-down but if you do this has to go
for a drop-down which is also very nice
the way I'd probably do this is you know
as soon as the text field is focused
drop down the list and then you know as
it loses focus you know collapse that
list as an alternative you could have
like an additional kind of spinner type
affordance on the side that pops up the
list but generally you know it's
probably best to just show the list
immediately and I think that's that may
be how the autocomplete stuff works by
default but not not quite sure
great cool another sign oh we've hit it
we've added here is to prefer email to
usernames I don't know about you but I
just find when I'm forced to pick like a
username rather than just using my email
address it's just another thing I'm not
going to remember whereas you know it
all comes back to email at the end of
the day anyway so you can reset it and
so forth so the worst is when there is a
service where the username is your email
and it says username like just say email
like just ask for the person's email
absolutely and yeah and it works really
really well on Android because you be
able to query their device for no ones
as well okay so next up with passwords
so we've said here like make it optional
so you can either you know just not
require users to enter a password you
could do something like auto-generating
one like pre fill it in and let them
slide code or something like that you
could just say it's optional some users
will want to set it some users might not
but my preferred option would be just to
probably admit it all together I mean
I'm probably going to enter something
very weak or very quick in anyway I'd
rather just you know it's in the
backgrounds generated its own super
secure or something like that and then I
can always just hit there you know
forgot password or reset button should I
really you know want to get access to
that password or you know getting any
I've forgotten that somehow same and
maybe later when you're on your desktop
when you have a real keyboard you can
get that email and actually fill out a
real password or something like that
yeah get the email I click here to
actually set a password so thinking back
through that kind of funnel an allergy
like how many people are gonna get
through this steps if you think back to
that first screen with all those files
and so on rather than just one which is
going to help me fill in the only field
anyway by suggesting something in a bunt
hit sign up you've got to imagine that
the funnel isn't a lot better for this
one thing I wanted to add is I guess
with passwords one of the one of my
biggest pet peeves is when there's like
passwords that require symbols and
capital letters and and all this stuff
and generally you know people it's a bad
practice but a lot of people use the
same type of password or the same you
know is it you know I might even be a
strong password might be very long but
you know people like to use similar
passwords and when you
ask them to start introducing like
cymbals and and you know all these
arbitrary constraints it actually makes
them forget their password I mean I
don't know how many times I know it's a
bank password but some my bank password
is like I mean I probably had to reset
them a bunch of times
we're like my my you know account for
like cable or something like that
generally you know try to try to enforce
it maybe on minimum size but not so much
on symbols and there's actually a really
funny xkcd about like arbitrary password
restrictions
basically like I think the result was
that if you have a very long string of
just regular words like hello there my
name is John or something and if they're
completely random words with no symbols
no anything the entropy of that is
actually a lot higher than a very short
password let's say 8 characters long
with a whole bunch of symbols and stuff
so you know think about that before you
require people to use or to provide
settings generally just don't get into
the game of holding passwords if you can
I think there's social providers you
know Facebook Google Twitter spend a lot
of kind of time and money in the foreign
engineering into keeping things like
this secure and if you have the option
of not doing that that's pretty
attractive I think you don't want to be
the one who loses someone's part of a
database of passwords or something right
exactly what Evernote tiny one here but
is that you can also help these are out
like replacing where they enter key will
be on the on the keyboard with some kind
of text st. you know which is contextual
to what you're doing so you know that
you're quite kind of program to type and
then hit next or whatever that button is
and if that actually does something you
know one user hits that it's the same as
hitting the on-screen signup button it
can is just another tiny thing that will
help me use it to kind of complete this
flow easier yeah yeah I guess similar to
that as well in case there's other
fields that you need to click like maybe
a phone number you know you can set the
data type on that field appropriately so
the keyboard adjusts itself to sort of
optimize for that field and actually
notice that here this is an email type
field so you automatically get the @
sign and a bad sign mmm and there's
other fields we talked about email quite
a lot that you can create their device
for I mean there's other fields you can
create for from I think Ice Cream
Sandwich and beyond
the device has a concept of a pro for
the user's profile so with a permission
you can ask for their first name last
name and their avatar photo yeah after
photo you can also get telephone number
if you got on a phone type device so
each of these will cost you a permission
but it depends if they you know it's
critical to your signup orders then you
know that might ease it and you know
increase signups all right shall we move
on to on-screen overlays yeah sure let's
do it
so this is pretty quick but uh on-screen
overlays so the general rule of thumb
here is avoid them in a it's kinda like
hand-drawn style arrows coming out yeah
yeah exactly
in particular you know you should avoid
them for common UI patterns so you know
we're talking action bar you really
don't need to tell the user how to use
these things again you know the other
thing we've been yeah the other thing we
mentioned here was the the navigation
drawer and and I think we mentioned this
yet but there's actually a recommended
pattern for the navigation drawer that
when the user first loads the app you
actually opened that navigation drawer
for them just so for discoverability
almost like a tutorial in itself
suggestion exactly and then the you know
the first time actually go and use the
drawer they close it or open it
themselves you can set a flag there and
then you don't need to open it again on
future future times they open the
application so you know you really don't
need an onscreen overlay to sort of help
the user discover that drawer you can
use another method like that other users
are learning things like the drawer like
the action bar overflow they're learning
things by using things like you know
apps like Gmail like Google keep Google
Drive you know a lot of these apps come
pre-installed on their devices before
they you know before they ever install
your app so they're learning these
patterns there's no need to really kind
of educate them further about patterns
they probably already know mm-hmm when
it comes to help you know the perfect
place to that is the overflow menu and I
think earlier on Roman had a link to the
design guidelines which sort of goes
into a bit more detail on how help
should be structured within your
application
yeah it's basically like the difference
between unsolicited help and solicited
help it's kind of like put users like
crying out for help they're gonna go to
the overflow and find what they need
there now there is there's there is
sometimes where it's appropriate to have
on-screen overlays though so custom
gestures like sort of very specific
gestures to your application that are
just very custom and interesting and
different to other applications it can
be appropriate and a really good example
of that here that we have in the
screenshot is the YouTube application
and so the one of the more recent
updates the YouTube application actually
allowed you allows you to basically
continue to browse YouTube while
minimizing the current video that's
playing and so in the bottom right there
that video would be playing right now
and the first time that you see this in
the new YouTube application it gives you
this little overlay so that you can sort
of understand the gestures that you can
apply to that particular video so
swiping there to the left
dismisses the video and swiping up
actually maximizes a video back into
sort of the fullscreen view so I think
this is a really good use of an overlay
yeah okay so I think that's all we have
this week on the onboarding experience
so thanks very much for joining us and
as always I'm your host Nick butcher
Roman Nurik Adam Koch see you guys